we are now approaching the most
important phase of development so far we
will define how he'll blade will look
feel and play the goal is to create a
small section of the game about 10 to 15
minutes in length to a near finish
standard this is what we call a vertical
slice and it's something that we've done
for all of our games but this time the
stakes are higher the independent
triple-a model is an experiment to see
if we can do a triple a quality game but
with an indie size team and budget and
the vertical slice was going to be a
crucial test for this model so far we've
worked out new ways of working for every
part of the game we had a test scene we
shot in our capture studio the basics of
our combat engine up and running we had
an idea of how to build the world in
Helheim some music recorded by annie
leblanc and an approach for creating
enemies making them all work together in
gameplay would be a major challenge dan
started working on a new type of
environment or forest set in the
outskirts of Helheim while I strict the
testing that we shot in our last every
and placed it within this setting
and to fill out some of the story
elements we turn to side UK in London
they helped us cast actors and record
some dialogues for use in the vertical
slice with that we started introducing
some non-combat based gameplay into the
level based on our ideas for story and
altered perception we had a new
character design which we modeled and
textured an animated and in tandem
decoders and gameplay team were working
on the AI systems to make sure he's fun
to play against after ten weeks of work
we had a level in place they could be
played from start to finish but this is
just the beginning of the process it's
very difficult to judge your own work
you're too close to the project so we're
two buyers to know whether what we
create is going to work for other
players we have a small room set up in
the studio equipped with a mic and a
camera a couple of people from another
team were invited to play the game or
the help aid team sat in another room
and watched the session dan goes smooth
in fact it was best described as a
disaster the combat was really messy and
unclear in a new setting and AI was
really frustrating for players the level
was described is too small to linear too
awkward to navigate and yet despite this
people were still getting lost
seonhwa herself felt very flat and
unconnected with the world just not
believable the team were despondent as
the reality of the session hit home we'd
failed to create the experience that
we've been looking for but you have to
start at rock bottom before you can even
attempt to reach for the top in my
experience it usually takes about three
goes to make something work and five to
make it good the team gathered to make
notes on issues and improvements that we
wanted to make you made a big list and
got back to work to fix the layout
problems we made the level a lot less
linear expanded it opened it up and
trust it so it helped guide the player
without them really being aware of it
Jeff and new character arts has joined
at this point and he started by creating
a new enemy variant to add more
diversity to the combat
to make Sonora feel more believable we
added a system of partial animation so
that she could physically react and
portray the mood that she's in to make
the combat feel very clear to the player
we animated all of the enemy attacks
from scratch and we also gave different
visual and sound effects for every
single type of attack in the game four
weeks later we were pretty confident
that we addressed most of the issues so
we ran another play test as we watch the
play test session the game pretty
quickly unraveled before our eyes now it
wasn't as bad as the last time so at
least we knew we were going in the right
direction but it was clear we still had
a lot of work to do Sony at this point
invited us to get the game into the
hands of journalists at a pre e3 event
called judges dead the deadline for this
meant that we only had two weeks to get
the vertical slice into shape and so we
created another massive list but with
only two weeks left it was looking
pretty tight at this point the initial
vertical slice took 10 weeks to put
together the second path took four weeks
and the third two weeks
what we've learned creating a vertical
slice has given us confidence to face
the next set of challenges and
development that's what the true value
of the vertical slices is not really
necessarily the end result but it is the
setbacks learning through repeated
failure to find the heart of what you're
searching for
I see
the final plate s of the vertical slice
will be in the hands of the journalists
at judge's day will be presenting the
game behind closed doors and we'll find
out if our work has paid off regardless
we'll be sharing the highlights of the
vertical slice before e3
see me